[Music]
thank you
now speaking of opportunities opening up
on the political right there's been a
big conference in London this week in
Westminster the national conservatism
conference which is a an American Import
but starred lots of Tory MPS and various
conservative figures from the
anglo-american community
um and two of the speakers at that
conference join me now
um Tim Stanley of the Telegraph and Mary
Harrington of unheard
um Tim perhaps you could start by
telling our viewers a little bit about
what national conservatism is what this
particular movement is and what they're
trying to do and could you also tell us
whether they succeeded in doing it in
London this week
someone put it to me brilliantly that
this conference was a seminar
masquerading as a rally
so some academics put on a seminar in
the center of London they invited
politicians and the politicians then
turned it into a platform to make it a
debate about the future of the
conservative party so to back up a
little bit there is an academic who's
Israeli called uran hazoni who is an
expert on conservative political Theory
a little bit of Zionism blended with
some
nationalism with some American
exceptionalism and of course he's got a
profound interest in Britain as well
because Britain is the home of
Enlightenment era conservative thinking
and has only wrote a couple of books
about conservatism and about nationalism
and came up with this uh well I wouldn't
say I want to say came up with the idea
it's been around for a while but he he
helped to uh to make concrete this idea
that at the center of conservative
thinking should be the life of the
nation not the individual not free
markets not getting rich but actually
making your country a better happier
healthier place it's about re-routing
the individual within their community
uh he also argues that because it's
about the nation conservatism will look
different from one place to another
it's National conservatism has managed
to get a big intellectual audience in
the United States it's got some money
behind it and they have been traveling
the world for the last couple of years
holding conferences in various places uh
they've been I think to Italy they've
been to Belgium been to America and now
they're here in Britain and in each case
the reaction and the response has been
different and the nature of the
conference has been different in a way
that reflects that idea that
conservatism will vary from one country
to another
so as I said National conservatism came
to London they invited politicians and
they happened to do so at a moment in
which the conservative party is cracking
up and uh a sort of a section of the
Parliamentary conservative party which
is socially conservative I'd say quite a
quite a small section and which is
grouped around sowella Braverman took
this as an opportunity to get a platform
to lay out their ideas about nationhood
and of course probably in this country
right now the most potent conservative
national issue is immigration and that
was the one that came up repeatedly but
as I say there's there's a slight
tension between what some of us were
there to do at the conference which was
to share ideas discuss hazoni's work
provide criticism and there was a lot of
criticism as well and what politicians
did which was turn up and make speeches
that got headlines which was fantastic
for building the brand of national
conservatism because even though uh it's
not terribly well known and a lot of
people still don't know who Professor
has only is uh that phrase is now on
everyone's lips in Westminster
Mary you were talking about biology and
feminism and not Party politics do you
agree with Tim that though I mean I
thought perhaps it was I came and saw
some of your speeches uh I thought it
was a shame in a way that this sort of
potentially quite interesting subject to
debate obviously controversial Liberty
makes headlines and so on but it did
also become a sort of uh it felt a bit
like Tory Party Conference the the
right-wing version
perhaps a little bit I mean my sense
um from
from spending some time in the in the
breakout conversations and and really in
the in the speeches as well is that
there are great many parallels with
um with with some of the national
conservatives and conferences that I've
attended elsewhere actually and on on
this in the sense that if you if you
have a conversation about conservative
invariant conservatism invariably there
are going to be some politicians there
and politicians are going to politics
that's what they do
um so invariably you're going to get
some stunt speeches and you're going to
get some people who are thinking very
concretely about how this is going to
place your electorates and and really
singing singing a tune in that key
um but there are a great many other
reasons to attend a conference like that
and one of the things that came across
very clearly to me was that there's a
much as much as I've written about this
before much as on other similar
occasions even elsewhere there's there's
quite a noticeable difference between
the way they typically typically older
politicians making stunt speeches are
thinking about these questions and and
the way some of the younger attendees of
which there are surprisingly many I mean
when I I was when I 20 years ago if you
went to a conservatism event it was
mostly sort of across the old buffers in
corduroy and there was a sense that you
get in some Anglican provincial Anglican
churches that there's really nobody
there under pretty much under retirement
age and that it wasn't like that at all
I think something like 40 of the
attendees at the event in London that
just finished were under 30.
um you know start uh really for a for a
conservative event a surprising number
of them were students I spoke to a great
many 22 23 year old young men and women
who are really grappling with you know
the big questions and I think and there
was a there was a very noticeable Gulf
between the way those young people were
approaching these questions and the way
the stump speech makers who who are
really engaging with a Westminster
political audience were were approaching
these questions now I think it's it's
good and healthy and right that we're
going to have different approaches and
different different priorities you know
within within an overall umbrella but it
was it was very interesting to bring
those groups together and to begin to
tease out where some of those some of
those blind spots are and I think there
are there's potentially some some
reflection to be done on on that on
those gaps
um that that might be beneficial overall
to people within Westminster going
forward
Tim you've written a lot about American
politics and I'm sure you've been to uh
American conferences like that about
conservatism and there's there's a lot
of that in America you know with the
conservatism is a big question that the
right has been asking itself for ages do
you think it suits uh British tourism to
have these uh sort of sometimes quite
intellectualized conversations does is
it something that American movement
conservatives and can sort of adapt into
British conservatism
yeah a lot of the media pounced on the
idea that this is an American Import and
even an American infiltration and
takeover of the conservative party uh
but Freddie you've been to U.S
conferences and as you know they always
begin uh with smoke machines with the
eye of the tiger uh and with a woman and
a man coming out and saying hi thank you
for coming whoa there was none of that
in fact there were barely any American
speakers uh and indeed there was a great
deal of media misrepresentation of the
conference and the people who spoke at
it uh this was in some regards one of
the most multi-ethnic Multicultural
multi-religious conferences that I have
been to in this country and some of the
speakers who attacked for individual
things they said so the speaker who said
we're not having enough babies was a
woman
um Sue Ella Brave him and the speaker
who said we need to do more to control
immigration is a person of color uh
yoram hazoni uh is himself Israeli there
were a large number of Jewish delegates
there so so the idea that this this was
some kind of right-wing
ethno-nationalist thing I found really
quite Preposterous and was based upon
one or two tweets which were put out by
the by the organization's media team who
obviously themselves took no offense at
those particular tweets
um but does this is this does this go
down well well I think if they don't do
this there's really nothing else uh
you're right by the infrastructurally in
America there are things like Heritage
which do this sort of conference all the
time and they bring people from across a
very much larger country who wouldn't
otherwise not meet and they get to share
ideas and they get to promote
candidacies and things like that
um we hadn't really been doing that in
Britain and that helps to explain why
there's a paucity of fresh ideas and
some of the ideas coming out of this
conference we really went against the
grain of British conservative thinking
and in some ways the conference was more
left-wing than it was reported and was
understood so for example Danny Krueger
gave a speech where again people jumped
upon the fact that he referred to the
normative family we can have a debate
about whether or not that is an accurate
or fair or kind description of families
but if you read the other 99 of the
speech he was essentially saying that
many of the problems of Britain are down
to conservative economics and have been
down to the legacy of thatcherism and
individualism and atomization so
actually some of the speakers at this
conference are on a journey towards the
left not towards the right and it's very
frustrating that people didn't look
beyond the tweets and actually noticed
that Mary do you not think this has been
talked about in in the media and in uh
perhaps highbrow circles at the right
you could call them uh for a long time
uh post-liberalism red tourism blue
labor there's a there's an there's long
been a feeling that something new has
got to happen in politics Beyond uh the
you know the Thatcher Reagan
neoliberalism if you like that's not a
great word for it but I think that's
what most people use and yet it never
really has materialized beyond the odd
conference the odd sort of moment where
people get excited about it it doesn't
really speak to electorates
I think you're right I mean it's it's
too early to tell I think as as a
Chinese Premier once said about the
French Revolution whether or not it
worked it's it's too early to tell
whether this is never going to
materialize one of the things actually I
thought was interesting about the the
really very strong media reaction and I
and I agree with Tim when he says that I
think it's been that there have been
some bad faith representations of what
was discussed I mean one of the one of
the standout speeches for me wasn't was
an economist who was making the case
that capitalism is structurally
antenatalist and this is not simply an
effect of bad policy this is not simply
an effective you know real factualism
has never been tried this is structural
and
and they and there are great many other
social ills that it propagates besides
which is a profanity profoundly left of
the idea and I think the The Thinker
that was referenced most frequently in
that speech was Karl Marx and this is
not something that the guardian is ever
going to report about National
conservatives and Conference because it
just doesn't compute but I think one of
the things that was that was interesting
about this conference and about the very
intense and sometimes bad faith media
representation of it is that up until
now as you say post-liberal ideas or you
know this sort of caucus of I did the
upper right hand quadrant I think as as
the Nerds call it you know they've
economically left and and socially right
um quadrant of ideas has been sort of
kicking around amongst politics nerds
for some time
um but has hasn't has yet to gain any
sort of mainstream traction I think part
of the issue there is that there has
been a great deal of um
amongst the respectable people it's
there's a certain amount of effort
that's gone into making sure that those
ideas are non-you and in as much as they
appear at all and it's they've been
they've been fairly methodically coded
as low status and there's not there's
just not something that ever gets
discussed amongst respectable people in
in zone one it just doesn't happen and I
think part of the reason the media's
been so upset about this conference is
that this that's just not manifesting
not the case you know here's a
conference where really those ideas are
being discussed and it's happening in
Westminster
um and and furthermore there are there
are some quite there are some household
names there and so and so in that sense
I mean it it's probably too early to
tell whether any whether it really this
is just going to end up being recouped
as some critics from the right have
suggested by you know the sort of
neoliberalism in a in a fancy dress you
know with some with neoliberalism plus
culture war is the worst case scenario
really you know that this this just gets
recouped and we get more of the same
with with occasional dire tribes about
work
um but it's it's too early to tell
otherwise whether it's going to go that
way or whether in fact some of the some
of the more interesting thinking and the
more creative thinking which which I I
agree is still is still Fringe relative
to the stump speech stuff but there's
there's still a chance that some of that
might percolate through
um and and I think it's if it does so it
will be in the teeth of all the
respectable people working very hard to
code it as low status and there's just
not something which is even within the
Overton window but the fact that this
conference happened in Westminster was a
it was a fairly a fairly forceful shove
against the parameters of the Overton
window and I think that's a that's a
positive step it really is Tim we just
had Nigel farage uh on spectator TV and
he was talking about
um how the Tory party always survives
somehow because uh despite uh the fact
it's probably going to face uh an
election loss in in the coming months uh
do you think look at the way British
Tory politicians treated this conference
do you think the conservative party is
going to adapt to this movement
um or is it going to shun it how is it
going to adapt and survive
some of the biggest pushback against the
conference came from what you might call
liberal conservatives many of whom did
not attend it didn't pay attention to
what was said I was just out on a side
note by the way I was struck by the
things that were not discussed at this
conference no one said bring back the
British Empire no one said ban abortion
there's a whole host of old issues which
are totally off the table now and
everyone's moved on from and yet they're
the things that there's often an
assumption right-wingers are saying and
they're simply not part of their
narrative at all anymore but there was a
big pushback among liberal conservatives
who are very powerful and influential
within the party that said I think a way
away from the conference there is a
growing and influential group of people
who feel that the economic policy
approach has been wrong we need more
industrial policy I wouldn't say
protectionism versus free trade that's a
very that's a silly way of simplifying
it but there's a sense that there's got
to be a move away from the idea that the
job of government is simply to get out
the way and and that I think is the most
significant shift in conservative things
thinking and you might even find it
among some liberal conservatives some
Tories are starting to say we have an
idea of how people ought to be living
they should be having families they
should be buying homes but the economic
situation doesn't actually allow them to
do that so how do we create the material
circumstances under which people can do
those things uh and some of that might
involve creative government action now
they're so fought to give a concrete
example uh the debate around the best
way to do child care we all know that
one reason why people are not having
children where when people are not
settling down is because of the
extortionate cost of raising a child and
now I think almost everyone's recognized
that within the conservative party that
that's a failing and that's a failure
that's happened under the Tories the
debate is should it be through the state
sponsoring child care where you leave
your kid with someone or as people like
Miriam Cates and some of the national
conservatives would prefer the state
making it more making it easier for
women to stay at home and raise the
child themselves so there's a cultural
Clash over what do women want but
actually I think conservatives are
coming around to the idea that there are
areas of policy that government has to
take an interest in even if it starts to
sound a bit like socialism because if
they don't do it you end up with a very
unconservative outcome which is people
not having babies or dropping out of the
workforce which is bad for the hallowed
word growth
where you you spoke about uh women the
body biology uh but I've noticed there
wasn't a lot of talk about the NHS or
the National Health Service do you think
that's because it's not a policy
um conference it's a it's an ideas
conference or do you think it's because
nobody really wants to tackle the NHS on
the right one way or the other
it's a very interesting question you
know I hadn't actually it hadn't
actually struck me until you pointed it
out just now that nobody was really
talking about the NHS uh at the
conference but you're absolutely right
nobody was talking about the NHS and to
be honest I think it's almost certainly
the case that nobody is tackling it
because it's just too big it's just too
big and and it touches on too much stuff
I mean I I forget who it was who quit
that you know we're now a Health Service
with a sort of vestigial country
attached and there is so that there is a
sense of that and nobody nobody quite
knows what to do about it and I mean I
think in in as much as it was referenced
it was probably obliquely
um in the several several talks actually
who spoke about the impossibility of
continuing an abundant welfare state
with a collapsing population which is
which is the the existential issue for a
lot of things and is a is an extremely
uncomfortable Wicked problem
um when you start looking at the
Confluence of you know the where where
social solidarity converges with high
taxation converges with support for the
welfare state support converges with
population
growth or shrinkage you know there's a
real Wicked problem there which which
we're already confronting I mean if
you're unless you're unless you're
pregnant or very old where I live in
small town in small town England you
know you can you you'll be lucky if you
get a GP appointment within six weeks
that's just that's just the reality in a
lot of places now
um if it's if people are if if people
weren't talking about it almost
certainly just because it's too big and
too radioactive I mean you can't you
can't do it in a 15-minute speech and
and people people are trying to but
maybe trying to zoom out a little bit
and thinking about the structural
questions which have brought us to the
point where where a Health Service with
a vestigial country attached and and
trying trying a few different angles to
see if we can see if we can come at some
of those some of those thorny issues
from from from different perspectives
and find creative ways of thinking about
it Tim you made uh the point in yourself
you did mention the National Health
Service because you said that people who
are uncomfortable with the national in
National conservatism should should
think about the National Health Service
yeah yeah obviously people are
uncomfortable about the word national
being involved being attached to a
political label because in their mind it
automatically goes to national socialism
and I joked that uh if that is the case
then we're also going to crack down on
the National Trust the nspcc and the NHS
um but Mary's right the NHS didn't come
up I think that's partly because this is
an academic audience because there was
some transatlantic crossover and it's
not a debate which I think some of our
guests would have particularly
understood or enjoyed in the same way
that I'm I'm not sure if you had this
kind of conference it would have been
appropriate to discuss Medicare and the
very particular debates around health
insurance in the United States the other
issue we did not discuss is Ukraine
which I think was partly a conscious
decision by the conference uh because if
you open up a conversation about Ukraine
I don't think you'd get anyone who says
Vladimir Putin's great but you're always
terrified someone's going to turn up to
speak who is Russian adjacent right uh
who is sympathetic in some way uh and I
think there's a little bit of political
control there the conference didn't want
to go down that rabbit hole but I think
it might also just be that there's
another issue that we didn't discuss
because it's not something that's part
of the British rights vocabulary There
is almost 99.9 support for Ukraine among
British conservatives and so there was
no real need to touch it because we are
pretty much United on that subject well
uh it's not that I don't want to go down
that rabbit hole but we do have to wrap
that up so um thank you very much Tim
and thank you Mary
[Music]
thank you